nadège bonjour alors quels sont les
premiers éléments qu'on peut retenir
juste à l'issue de ce discours du
premier ministre
première annonce importante il n'y aura
pas de déconfinement au 11 mai si les
français ne respectent pas le
confinement d'ici là si le nombre de
contamination augmente le confinement
n'aura pas lieu dans 13 jours ou alors
elle se fera de manière très stricte le
confinement a été un instrument efficace
pour lutter contre la propagation du
coït 19 selon le premier ministre ce
confinement a permis d'éviter 62 mille
décès sur un mois at il dit nous allons
devoir vivre avec le virus pas de
traitement efficace pas de vaccin nous
allons devoir apprendre à nous en
protéger le risque d'une deuxième vague
n'est pas à exclure elle est à prendre
au sérieux
protégez tester isolé c'est la formule
choisie par le premier ministre pour
illustrer son plan de lutte contre le
coc vide 19 à partir du 11 mai il a
rappelé l'importance 1 à nouveau du
respect des gestes barrières du respect
de la distanciation social distanciation
physique 1 c'est ce mot et qu'il a
choisie au détriment de 2,2 social au
sujet du port du masque il a dit il y
aura suffisamment de masques pour tout
le monde ils seront elles disponibles
dans les différents commerces 700 mille
tests pourront avoir lieu à partir du 11
mai les personnes malades pourront
devons être isolé au sujet des écoles la
réouverture progressive des écoles
maternelles et primaires se fera sur la
base du volontariat on le sait depuis
quelques quelques jours déjà
au sujet des aides et des collèges il se
fera elle se fera à partir du 18 mai
cette réouverture pour les classes de 6e
et 5e sur elle et lycées est la décision
sera prise à la fin du mois de mai pour
une éventuelle réouverture
au mois de
joint donc une réouverture progressive
qui se fera dans des conditions
sanitaires très strictes pas plus de 15
élèves par classe avec une distribution
de gel hydroalcoolique les démasque et
distribué quand les règles de
distanciation sociale ne pourront pas
être respectées je vous propose
d'écouter edouard philippe à ce sujet
nous proposons une réouverture très
progressive des maternelle et de l'école
élémentaire à compter du 11 mai partout
sur le territoire et sur la base du
volontariat
dans un deuxième temps à compter du 18
mai mais seulement dans les départements
où la circulation du virus est très
faible
nous pourrons envisager d'ouvrir les
collèges en commençant par les classes
de 6e et de 5e
nous déciderons fin mais si nous pouvons
réouvrir les lycées en commençant par
les lycées professionnels
début juin la réouverture des écoles est
nécessaire pour garantir la réussite
éducative des élèves notamment les plus
vulnérables d'entre eux dont la
scolarité souple souffre terriblement du
confinement les classes rouvriront dans
des conditions sanitaires strictes à
plus de 15 élèves par classe une vie
scolaire organisée autour du respect des
règles barrière de mesures d'hygiène
strictes et de la distribution de gel
hydroalcoolique tous les enseignants et
encadrants des établissements scolaires
recevront des masques qu'ils devront
porter quand ils ne pourront respecter
les règles de distanciation
le télétravail devra être maintenu
autant que possible dit le premier
ministre du moins pour les trois
prochaines semaines
en ce qui concerne les commerces ils
pourront réouvrir à partir du 11 mai
excepté les cafés et les restaurants la
décision de la réouverture de ces
commerces cela sera prise à la fin du
mois de mai je vous propose d'écouter
aller précision d'edouard philippe à ce
sujet si les commerces vont rouvrir
chacun d'entre eux devra respecter un
cahier des charges strict limitant le
nombre de personnes présentes en même
temps dans le magasin en organisant les
flux afin de faire respecter la règle de
la distance minimale d'un mètre par
personne sans contact autour d'elle il
devra bien évidemment veiller à la
protection de son personnel
s'agissant du port du masque le port du
masque grand public sera recommandée
pour les personnels et les clients
lorsque les mesures de distanciation
physique ne peuvent être garantis un
commerçant pourra subordonnés l'accès de
son magasin au port du masque j'ajoute
enfin que l'ouverture des commerces
comprendra une exception pour les
centres commerciaux qui ont une zone de
chalandise qui va au delà du bassin de
vie et donc qui génère des déplacements
et des contacts que nous ne voulons pas
encourager les préfets pourront décider
de ne pas laisser ouvrir au delà
défection alimentaire déjà ouvertes
les centres commerciaux de plus de 40
mille mètres carrés qui risque de
susciter de tels mouvements de
population enfin je les dis nous
prendrons une décision sur les bars
cafés et restaurants fin mai pour
décider s'ils peuvent ouvrir après le 2
juin le port du masque sera également
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun rer bus et métros les opérateurs
devront faire respecter les règles de
distanciation social un siège sur deux
devra être condamné notamment dans les
trains dans les bus dans les trams ou et
il ne sera pas possible de pratiquer des
sports dans des lieux couverts
le sport collectif ou de contacter à
partir du 11 mai elle les plages seront
inaccessibles
jusqu'au 1er juin les médiathèques
bibliothèques petit musée pourront
réouvrir ce qui ne sera pas le cas des
grands musées cinémas qui ne pourront
pas ouvrir avant le 2 juin les grandes
manifestations sportives et culturelles
de plus de 5000 personnes ne pourront
pas se tenir avant le mois de septembre
et puis les lieux de culte ans pourront
réouvrir à partir du 11 mai sans grande
cérémonie avant le 2 juin protéger les
français sans immobiliser la france au
point où elles s'effondrerait c'est
l'une des formules prononcé par edouard
philippe aujourd'hui qui est bien une
heure une heure de prise de parole du
chef du gouvernement pour présenter ce
plan de déconfinement à suivre
maintenant à l'assemblée nationale un
débat où les parties parlement des
groupes parlementaires devront prendre
la parole avec un vote d'ici aux
alentours de 19 heures merci beaucoup
n'avaient pour toutes ces précisions on
a déjà des razak en direct devant
l'assemblée nationale